at competing rallies in El Paso Texas
President Trump
rhetoric League elds por bado O'Rourke
and the president is continuing to cut
down his opponents as Democrats scramble
after a particularly disastrous week
what a time to be alive and the 2020
race has just barely begun
then do animals feel pain and finally on
this day in history Reverend Henry
Highland garnet becomes the first black
man to address the US Congress we will
remember his excellent sermon I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
so much to get to today I wasn't
supposed to be with you all today I was
actually supposed to be on the road but
I was able to come back here to LA so
I'm very glad because there is so much
to get to I was in my hotel room in
Atlanta last night was about to go to
bed we had a great time at Emory
University and I came back and I turned
on the TV and there was president Trump
giving his El Paso speech his El Paso
rally his El Paso wal rally was so good
and I just thought man this guy is
really good at politics then down the
road poor little bado could barely get
anything going on he could barely be
heard over the sound of trump's superior
rally going on a quarter of a mile away
we will get to that in a second but
first let's make a little money honey
with purple mattress
purple mattress is tremendous you know
this I am a an evangelist of purple I'm
a proselytize for purple it is the best
bed that I've ever slept on purple
mattress is not an innerspring it's not
exactly a memory foam it's this new
technology it was developed by a rocket
scientist and it is both firm and soft
at the same time how is that possible I
couldn't possibly tell you it just feels
great I miss it every time I'm on the
road I love it I've been recommending it
to all of my friends you should check it
out
purple mattress also it will sleep cool
it sometimes beds just get really really
hot even in winter
purple mattress doesn't trap the heat
like that you'll just love it hundred i
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund
backed by 10-year warranty free shipping
and returns free in-home setup and old
mattress removal you will love it right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's an addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide Chuck's
text cough FA CoV f EF e two four seven
four seven four seven that is the only
way to get this free pillow text cough
fa right now do it CoV f EF e two four
seven four seven four seven c OV e fe fe
four seven four seven four seven message
and data rates may apply this trump
rally was so good if you missed it go
back and watch the whole thing afterward
he went on for over an hour
the man has such stamina
he both had a speech he was reading in
parts from a prompter and then he would
just go off on these trumpian riffs that
were so effective my main takeaway from
it was that this guy is so surprisingly
good at politics we should not be
surprised by this anymore he's a people
were tweeting they said oh you know he
really is likeable oh he really is
somewhat charming and you think oh the
guy who was a celebrity for 40 years and
then the king of television and then got
himself elected to the most important
political office in the world on his
first try that guy might be a little
charming I think he is I think he's
slightly charming you just forget it
sometimes you forget it because the
media tell you that he's some bumbling
idiot who doesn't know anything about
politics he's never even heard of I
don't know energy policy he doesn't even
what is the Congress he doesn't even
know what the Congress is just a big
bumbling fool who accidentally keeps
finding himself in these incredible
situations is the ferrisbueller of
politicians I guess you can tell he's
really good at at this political rally
game and you can tell he's getting even
better at it here is the message that
President Trump has found in recent
weeks and he really needs to hammer home
all Republicans should be hammering home
on the wall this one cuts through all of
the noise our rich liberals and wealthy
donors these are hypocrites who oppose
security for you while living their
entire lives I do too to be honest with
you I'm guilty I'm guilty I also live
behind walls okay they live behind walls
and gates and they have guards all over
the place me too because I want to be
safe and I want to make America safe if
you don't mind
what a great line of attack this is a
very trumpian setup this is one of the
great setups that helped him in 2016
which is you call out hypocrisy you call
out corruption then you say that you
also participated in that you also
participated in this elitism and then
you say I see it clearly and I want
everyone to enjoy the fruits of elitism
I want everyone to be able to live like
I do
it's an essentially American message
it sort of grants a little bit of a vice
or it's it's like he's letting you in on
a little secret
even though it's not a secret we all
know Donald Trump lived behind walls
because he's a billionaire but it's it's
allowing that connection and saying hey
come here I got something to tell you
it's rhetorically extraordinarily
effective but you saw him do this in
2016 he said look I don't need to take
anybody's money I don't need to take
money from any of the big donors me I
was buying off politicians left and
right when I was a developer in New York
oh yeah was buying them all off
Democrats Republicans everybody and I'm
telling you I've seen how it works I've
seen it up close and I'm not gonna be
that guy for you I don't need their
money I'm letting you in on the secret
I participated in that and it's wrong
because some people got to do it and
some people don't it granted access to
some people but not others and I'm
telling you now I'm gonna clean up
government I'm gonna drain the swamp
rhetorically very effective he's doing
the same thing here he's saying the
people who oppose the wall all live
behind walls this is true 100% of the
time some live behind really big giant
gated mansions like Nancy Pelosi but
everybody's got walls everybody's got a
lock on their door everybody's got walls
in their house and these members of
Congress many of them have security they
travel with security they travel with
guys with guns
it's just you who doesn't get to have
them and he's saying I want to give that
to everybody I want everybody to be just
as safe as these hypocrite Democrat
billionaires and these donors and these
members of Congress he's not even just
on the Democrats because there are
donors in both parties this this was
always the unholy alliance that gave us
illegal immigration is that Democrats
wanted to import them for votes and the
sort of wall street journal' Republicans
said the Chamber of Commerce Republicans
that wanted to import them for cheap
labor so they both would turn a blind
eye and in some cases even encourage
illegal immigration Donald Trump's going
in and saying yep that's a crooked deal
that's a raw deal they're hypocrites
they're enjoying the fruits of security
you should too
this works for the gun control argument
as well so these guys are hypocrites
they've got armed guards with them at
all times you should be able to be an
armed guard for yourself and you should
be able to give your family an armed
guard in yourself you should be able to
carry your guns and I'm gonna do that
and it's a totally American message
because instead of just tearing down the
elite saying you billionaires are
immoral like aoc just said or people who
have succeeded or terrible we should
tear them down that's a very unamerican
message Donald Trump gives the American
message he says yeah I was buying off
politicians left and right and I'm gonna
be I'm gonna be buying off myself for
you I'm gonna be giving you the
opportunity you can buy me off with your
votes
I'm unaccountable to all you I'm gonna
be influenced not by special interests
but by you the American people yeah I've
been living behind gates my whole life
and I'm gonna extend that to you so that
you can live like the elites yeah the
elites get to be behind the protection
of armed guards all the time I'm gonna
extend that to you you can live like the
elites a totally uplifting message and
the the other advantage for him is
there's no actual argument against the
wall so he's pushing really hard right
now he took a little bit of a personal
popularity hit during that government
shutdown and since then though his
popularity has really increased and he
is going hard at these people so bado
O'Rourke held a rally down the street a
tale of two rallies you know everybody
tells me that bado is a great politician
I've never met bado in person I've never
seen him personally on the stump or on
the campaign trail but people who were
people who were advisors to senator Cruz
and others who saw him up close they
he is a great politician however the
more light that is being shown on this
guy the less talented he seems take a
look at this in one of the safest cities
in the United States of America safe
not because of walls but in spite of
walls secure because we treat one
another with dignity and respect that is
the way that we make our communities and
our country safe o bado or ork women
don't want him men don't want to be him
how awkward first of all if you couldn't
see it his body movements are so awkward
and stilted you've got Donald Trump
behind his podium and he's he's got he
also just stick you lates but it doesn't
seem to be just stick ulation it seems
to he has a purpose behind his movements
whereas when you look at bado
he's a cool guy you know betas he's so
cool and modern
he doesn't need a jacket yeah dad you
can't make me wear a tie dad I'm cool
he's just doing that Obama thing you
know he's actually doing what I'm
wearing right now except I'm doing a
podcast he's giving a political rally
through all of his supporters you know I
can't be bothered to wear a jacket I'm a
cool guy mm-hmm so he's doing that I
don't need a podium dad so there he's
just walking around the stage and but
he's it's too awkward like his torso
isn't working I don't want people to
accuse me by the way of sexism because I
keep commenting on these female Democrat
presidential candidates on how they were
coming across physically I will also do
it for the male candidates the trouble
is that all of the candidates right now
are women right I think all of the
Democrat candidates Amy Klobuchar
Elizabeth war and Cory Booker or Kamala
Harris they're I it's only declared
women right now in the Democrat field so
when when men declare like when bado
finally comes out and runs I can point
to that as well Bob 800 Roarke is he's
just B's
he reminds me of that guy in college
that creepy guy in college who would go
up to your girlfriend and tell them that
like he's really way more sensitive than
your boyfriend is you know like he's
that guy he's that creepy male feminist
who writes diary entries on medium he
just uh he did not come off well in this
rally but but look at this difference
just look at this difference between in
one second there's a huge difference you
can tell the big difference between the
Trump rally in the bado rally in one
second first let's make a little money
honey with We the People holsters oh I
love We the People holsters they design
everything in-house we the people
holsters offer custom-made holsters all
produced in the USA they design them
in-house that means they don't use any
third-party models for their holsters
instead every unique mold comes out of
Las Vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly they're
constantly updating their designs adding
new designs every month lets them stay
up-to-date on the newest models that
come out We the People holsters even
have their own 3d design team that
measures every micro millimeter of their
guns to ensure the perfect fit their
unique and intuitive clip design allows
for you to easily adjust both the can't
and ride of your holster so that it will
fit comfortably and securely at all
times you are able to place the holster
on your waist your right on your
waistband that you can change the angle
it's really good it's got adjustable
retention its signaled with a click
sound this lets you know your firearm is
securely in place and don't cheap out
when you're when it comes to your
protection when it comes to your holster
get get a really high quality holster
that is custom designed it's gonna fit
your firearm and by the way you can get
them in with the people holsters they
start at just 37 dollars a piece
and they have really cool designs thin
blue line Constitution camo American
flags are really cool every holster
comes with a lifetime guarantee every
holster ships free if it's not a perfect
fit send it back for a refund check it
out right now listeners of the Michael
Nolt show mm-hmm you can go to We the
People holsters comm slash Knowles kano
wles promo code Knowles Canada wles a
checkout get $10 off your first holster
that's as low as $37
shipping is free additional $10 off
using that promo code we the people
holsters dot-com / Knowles Kenner wles
promo code Knowles at checkout for $10
off here is the difference between the
Trump rally and the bado rally in just
one clip back to back first you're gonna
see the Trump rally and then immediately
you will see the beta rally see if you
can tell the difference
where the action is
could you tell the difference it was a
subtle difference wasn't it I think that
by the way I'm not making that up that I
know that seems like just the sort of
joke I would say that the Trump rally
had people chanting USA USA and then the
bado rally was a mariachi band no no no
no they actually chanted USA at the
Trump rally and they actually had a
mariachi band
the bata rally there also obviously
showing the difference between the GOP
and the Democrats these days the GOP the
GOP broadly I think always positioned
itself as the pro-america party and the
Democrats at least since the 60s have
been the anti America party but at least
the Democrats tried to hide it they're
not really hiding it anymore they're not
doing a very good job at it they're now
saying one party the Republicans want
America to be a country and to remain a
country because we like our country and
our countrymen and then the Democrats
are saying bring in the mariachis
anything that looks American get it out
of here we want totally open borders
were ashamed that America exists that
shouldn't exist and it won't exist for
very long if we have anything to say
about it this also gets to a personal
difference between both Donald Trump and
bado or or bata O'Rourke is a fraud his
name is a fraud he pretends to be
Mexican he has this name Beto baito but
he's fully Irish he's the most Irish is
more Irish than Liz Warren is not Indian
and it's kind of a is a weird moment for
the Democrats that you've got these
racial frauds littering their
presidential primary but of course the
reason for this is because they've
embraced and identity politics and an
ideology called intersectionality that
says that white people are bad and if
white people are bad then these cynical
politicians are going to pretend not to
be white people like bado or org so
you've got bata who's a race fraud and
then you've got President Trump who is
not a fraud president Trump is many
things hey you couldn't accuse him of a
great many things but Donald Trump
what-you-see-is-what-you-get
that guy does not there is not a lot of
distance between him and the voter
Donald Trump
this rally last night Donald Trump is so
authentic that he actually came out
against puppies he came out he had been
talking about German shepherds this is
the setup he was talking about how at
the border they have all of these really
cool technology to find drugs and he
said but none of it's as effective as a
German Shepherd they bring the dug drug
dogs around and then the drug dogs sniff
out the drugs and then he goes on this
rant he's so authentic that he came out
against puppies
I wouldn't mind having one honestly but
I don't have any time by don't have how
would I look walking a dog on the White
House Lord would that be right
sort of not for I don't know it doesn't
I don't feel good feels a little phony
phony to me a lot of people say oh you
should get a dog why it's good
politically I said look that's not the
relationship I have with my food we want
to have yeah
Obama had a dog he nails it here
I found this glimpse so charming because
he says he's talking about dogs and all
these people like us to really like
their dogs I mean who doesn't like dogs
dogs are man's best friend he says all
you all love your dogs right yeah we
love our dogs yeah yeah maybe you should
I get add I don't have time for a dog
he's right he doesn't have time for a
dog yeah well he's what should I should
I walk around with a little dog yeah you
should walk around with the dog now it
would be phony I don't want a dog now
but it would be good politics that's not
the relationship I have with my people
he's right that's the thing and then he
laughs at that joke at the end yeah
Obama had a dog all right no dogs other
politicians do things so that they can
get a photo taken in the newspaper that
they think will test really well in the
focus groups with their supporters and
the moderates and old mate mister you
should get a dog okay I'll get a dog
I'll get a dog and I'll name it after me
do you remember that Barack Obama named
his dog after himself because he's a
ridiculous narcissist people called
Trump a narcissist
give me a Barack Obama named the dog
after him so I'll get a dog I'll look
really good love my dog
but Donald Trump is like me I'm sorry
this is another this is unpopular but
hey that's my relationship to you huh
just like the president I don't I don't
like dogs I'm not a dog person I'm not a
cat person
I'm a people person it's what I am
I like people I'm not a huge don't I
like dogs for five minutes and I if I go
to my friend's house I can play with
dog and then go away go cuz dogs are not
reasonable I can't reason with them so
after a while it's okay that's fine I
don't want to have to stay home and walk
them I don't want to have to now in LA
because the dogs or have taken over the
whole city now the dogs own people in LA
so when you go to restaurants it's just
all these dogs and they're all pretend
to service animals for like little
seventeen year old white girls who can't
go anywhere with that fluffy and they
completely take but I don't care I don't
I'm with Donald Trump I don't have time
I'm not that interested sorry
now most politicians would never say
that out of you it's like coming out
against apple pie say yeah I don't like
apple pie I'm not an apple pie person
nope uh-uh and but he does it because he
knows look I'm not gonna do some stupid
photo op for so that there's a photo in
the New York Times and then people think
I'm really soft and warm because I have
a dog I'm not doing that
I'm speaking very candidly to the
American people and to my supporters and
it works it totally works
so this rally this was a really nice way
to end the my trip on the road I had
been on the road in rally in Raleigh
North Carolina I was in Atlanta I was
supposed to go to Alabama but I ended up
coming straight back I'd been sick it
had been a really tough week I was
pretty rundown and I see this and it
totally reinvigorated me and I think it
totally reinvigorated his base and
Donald Trump is now on the warpath he is
going hard his his approval rating is
going up and so now he's he's going hard
not just against bado who he was
ruthlessly mocking during the rally but
now he's going after Democrat freshman
rep Elan Omar she's the one who said
that Israel had hypnotized the world and
we need to pray to Allah the people's
eyes are opened to the evil of Israel
you know a moderate she's a moderate
Democrat and so then she came out and
said that Jews are just buying off all
of the Republicans all those awful
terrible Jews are just buying them off
with their money and she tweeted out
this outcome Republicans support Israel
she said it's all about the Benjamins
baby just also a plan words because
Benjamin is a Jewish name and she's
referring to AIPAC the Israel PAC in
America as if to say the only reason
anybody would ever support Israel is
because they're on the hook for Jew
money that's her line that's her point
she's obviously not a huge fan of the
Jewish people or the State of Israel and
she just keeps doubling down in tweet
and statement all of these digs against
Jews and this has become too much for
some members of her party though her
party's been pretty silent on
anti-semitism Donald Trump feeling
strong coming off a good rally
he's coming out and says she should
resign might want to say is that
anti-semitism has no place in the United
States Congress and congressman Omar is
terrible what she said and I think she
should either resign from Congress or
she should certainly resign from the
House Foreign Affairs Committee what she
said is so deep-seated in her heart that
her lame apology and that's what it was
it was lame and she didn't mean a word
of it was just not appropriate I think
she should resign from Congress frankly
but at a minimum she shouldn't be on
committees but certainly that committee
beautiful just coming out kicking the
Democrats while they're down has been a
very tough couple weeks for Democrats
they've had the green New Deal which
totally blew up in their face they've
got you know Eva Braun as a freshman
Democrat gangrel they have a few Eva
Braun's actually as a matter of fact
because they've got in the old days
anti-semitism was mostly a right-wing
issue obviously goes around a little bit
but it was mostly a right-wing issue
they they used to say that
anti-catholicism was the anti-semitism
of the left now anti-semitism is the
anti-semitism of the left the left keeps
trying to portray Donald Trump as a Nazi
they've been doing this now forever they
always do this to Republicans every
Republican president is Hitler they did
it to Reagan that it's a bush they're
doing it to to Trump now
I think Trump was smart to seize on this
moment and to really go after this
freshman congresswoman let's put this
into perspective the State of Israel has
named a train station in Jerusalem after
Donald Trump Donald Trump is the only
president who has actually kept his
promise though many many other
presidents have promised it he moved the
embassy in Israel to Jerusalem kept his
promise he has conservative and Orthodox
Jews as senior advisors his daughter
converted to Judaism it's very difficult
to make the case that Donald Trump is
anti-semitic meanwhile Democrats just
elected their new stars to Congress ilan
Omar praying that Allah opened people's
eyes to the evils of Israel Rashidah
Talib who in her office actually took
Israel off the map of the world and
replaced it with a sticky note that said
Palestine Palin around with anti-semites
Barack Obama Palin around with Louis
Farrakhan who calls the Jews termites
and they don't get held to account for
it because of the mainstream media so
Donald Trump on the warpath is using his
microphone to do it and anti-semitism
now is primarily a left-wing problem and
he is really putting the focus on that
absolutely he this is what he should be
doing it's only gonna cause this
approval rating to keep going up it said
what 52% it's gonna keep going up if he
keeps this up in the Democrats keep
imploding he's not the only one on the
warpath cocaine Mitch pulled
hid the best move that he is pulled
since the Kavanagh hearings we'll get to
that in a second plus a lot more to get
to we've got to get to Kamala Harris
smoking pot but first you've got to go
to daily wire.com if you're there thank
you very much you keep the lights on you
keep Kofi Fay in my cup if you are not
there please check it out it costs ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the end
replevin sure you get the Ben Shapiro so
you get the amount well sure you get
those questions and the mailbag that's
coming up on Thursday you get to ask
questions backstage we're like doing
those every day now practically you get
to get a
their kingdom but most importantly of
all the leftist ears tumblr you get mmm
this is really good because you know
Ilan Omar is praying that Allah open
people's eyes up and when when those
eyes are open especially those left-wing
eyes you know what's going to pour out
those leftist tears because Donald
Trump's approval ratings in 52% and beta
O'Rourke had a flop of a rally last
night and Kamala Harris is boasting
about house she smoked pot listening to
Snoop Dogg seven years before is that
first album came out oh it's just so oh
if I were on the left I would fill up
tumblr after tumblr this week but I
can't I'm just filling them up with
tears of joy I'm just that that most
popular emoji in the world you know the
one was just ha and then the tears of
joy come pouring out mix them in with
your leftist tears the tears of joy and
the leftist tears it creates that like a
nice rose a serves really well out of
your tumblr go to daily wire calm we'll
be right back
so cocaine Mitch wants to join in on the
fun you know cocaine Mitch isn't gonna
let President Trump have all the fun
oh no no no cocaine Mitch but what he
does they have very different styles
President Trump obviously he's a little
bigger more braggadocious a little more
he's just a bigger personality cocaine
Mitch he just waits there in his shell
he's just spying around the room in his
shell waiting for the opening to come
out and snap and he's found it in the
green new deal you remember the green
new deal it's gonna destroy 88 percent
of American energy knocked down every
single building in the country rebuild
it within 10 years outlaw airplanes
outlaw automobiles obviously gonna have
to leave your home when they knock the
building down it's going to destroy
one-sixth of the American economy
Institute socialist health care take
away unemployment insurance create
mandatory government jobs I guess that's
the backstop then it's gonna pay people
who are unwilling to work the list goes
on and on and on and on and do you know
who loves the green New Deal
other than all of us cocaine Mitch oh he
loves it
cocaine Mitch is going to bring the
green New Deal to the Senate floor for a
vote now obviously it's not going to
pass the Senate there are there's
Republican control of the Senate and
president Trump would veto it anyway
but what cocaine Mitch wants to do I'm
sorry
Senate Majority Leader cocaine what
Senate Majority Leader cocaine wants to
do is get every single Democrat senator
on the record as either supporting or
opposing the green New Deal this is a
perfect wedge issue especially because
environmentalism is the left's religion
so if you oppose it you're not just
opposing some policy they like you are
opposing their faith their Creed the
harsh of their identity and he wants to
get them on the record and they're
damned if they do damned if they don't
if they vote for the green New Deal
every single GOP ad in 2020 is going to
be about how senator so-and-so voted too
American energy to take away six million
jobs in two seconds and destroy your
house outlaw your car in your airplane
if they vote against the green New Deal
then the left is going to go after them
the ocasion cortez wing of the party is
going to go after them they're gonna be
seen as old fogies they might get
primary in 2020
it's a beautiful issue and so when
cocaine Mitch he always tries to hide
his excitement but he gives you a little
wink this is what he said he said quote
I've noted with great interest the green
New Deal and we're going to be voting on
that in the Senate give everybody an
opportunity to go on record and see how
they feel about the green New Deal
it's just that little it's like that
jiff of cocaine Mitch just looking up
and then you just see that little smile
creep across his face I'm sure that's
what he got when he was writing out that
statement absolutely fabulous how are
the Democrats punching back they've got
nothing so they're just punching back
and the old way they always do they
they're using the the mainstream media
of course there was at the media
Research Center they found I think
thirty three TV shows in the past I
don't know five minutes that have been
calling Donald Trump a racist a
terrorist it's and it's great to kill
babies and they're just using the
edifice that they have to do their best
to push down Trump's popularity push up
Democrat popularity here are their best
efforts Mike Pence's wife Karen or
mother as she's called during their BDSM
late-night ink sessions Donald Trump
races
Trump is holding this country hostage
you don't deal with terrorists mr.
president on the off-chance it you
aren't watching judge Jeanine Pirro with
your pants off right now
he has turned the Republican Party into
something different than it was when I
started to run for president yeah look
watch Kremlin a little premature to be
the lamenting the death of our democracy
that is exactly what everyone said in
those countries as human rights eroded
my greatest accomplishment oh we didn't
ask not getting aids from right calm
oh there go yeah ha ha see ha ha ha ha
president firms approval is at 52% in
the only daily presidential tracking
poll so said they did but they they had
the fake Jon Stewart talk about how bad
he is but some guy on some sitcom that
nobody watches he said it's bad it
uh-oh just doesn't their power has just
totally eroded this would have been
unthinkable ten years ago it really what
this is a whole new ballgame that we're
in and I think it's because so many
people don't have cable how many
Millennials do you know that actually
have television not very Millennials I
know use the streaming services maybe
they have their parents log in if they
want to watch a special or a game or
something on cable which they also
stream but they just don't so that power
of the mainstream media is totally goes
away it just hasn't worked at least and
that's they used to have the whole
edifice of the media now even that does
nothing for them so now they're pushing
this this lie that President Trump is
raised to their taxes because it's tax
season and the big stories being
reported everywhere some people are
finding that their tax refunds are lower
than they expected and so first of all
the basis of this story is some people
on Twitter that's it there's not like
there's some big study it's not like
there was a survey or no there was some
people on Twitter this was enough to get
the mainstream media riled up but you
might be asking yourself wait a second
how is that possible
we know that Republicans lowered taxes
last year in fact this was the big gripe
the big gripe against Trump last year
from the Democrats is Republicans
lowered taxes to
much and now the government won't have
enough of your money that was the big
gripe and now they're saying the
government has too much of your money
hi-c ha ha which is it you got to pick a
lane now let's say let's just do the
hypothetical and say that you get less
money in your tax refund this year your
tax refund is not a gift from the
government it's not like every year at
Christmastime big daddy government says
well ho ho ho
how much did Johnny Smith deserve this
year let's give him an extra $200 Oh No
the tax refund is your money it's your
money which you gave in an interest-free
loan to the federal government for a
whole year ideally you would not get a
tax refund because the government
wouldn't make you pay all of that money
up front that you don't owe them so
that's just on the basic front to begin
but on the second front stop using some
people on Twitter as your as your basis
mainstream media other than a handful of
people who did very well people who make
a decent amount of money in particular
blue states where they're also taxed a
lot at the municipal in the state level
everybody's taxes went down every that's
this is an empirical fact to say
otherwise is fake news it's why we
conservatives refer to these guys as
fake news so that one hasn't worked
either unfortunately for the left
presidential approval is up everybody is
doing well except for Democrats over the
past couple weeks so now what Democrat
presidential candidates are trying to do
is to be likable they can't run on
policy what policy can they run on the
green New Deal not gonna play in Peoria
they can't really run on their records
Kamala Harris is ostensibly the
frontrunner for the Democrats her entire
career as a prosecutor she can't run as
a prosecutor because Democrats hate law
enforcement they hate prosecutors
they're running against the cops they
want to abolish law enforcement so
you'll notice if I weren't telling you
this you probably would have no idea if
you're just a regular old American
walking around you listen to the news
every
so often you would probably have no idea
that Kamala Harris was a prosecutor for
her entire career because she won't talk
about it because she knows if she talks
about it it'll kill her in the primary
so now she's trying to be likable you
know that the generic Democrat the
generic Democrat could beat Donald Trump
I think in 2020 just the generic
Democrat that you could just put all
your hopes and dreams on but there's no
such thing as a generic Democrat there's
no such thing as a generic political
candidate period even Mitt Romney who is
the closest thing to generic that there
is is not generic we saw that they
painted him as a guy who is mean to his
dog didn't work out for him
plus he's also a snake who stabs his
friends in the back and he's completely
disloyal so that's that also helps when
your hurts rather when you're trying to
be the generic guy that you can put your
hopes and dreams on so Kamala Harris
doing her best now to seem likable see I
just want to prepare just set your face
in a cringe cuz it's gonna go there
anyway and I don't want it to scare you
when your snaps into a cringe cringe and
take a look at this are you kidding me I
do listen I think that it gives a lot of
people joy that laugh is like nails on a
chalkboard that laugh is so much worse
than Hillary's laugh because it she you
can tell she does it a little bit when
she's in
mr. she does it just to fill time orange
and it's jut rye to be likable it's so
awful I don't maybe it's genuine doesn't
matter either way she has got to fix the
laughs that laugh is I just like
twitching when I hear it
it's worse than Hillary's also we're a
long way from I did not inhale or Bill
Clinton in just a perfect example of a
clintonism he was asked if he'd ever
smoked pot I did smoke marijuana but I
did not inhale what so are you an idiot
if you not know when I was at Oxford
azrael you made it to Oxford as a Rhodes
Scholar you didn't know that the point
of smoking pot is to inhale so we've got
a long way here now these politicians
are going out of their way to say that
they have smoked pot and honestly I'm
not sure that I believe that Kamala
Harris has ever actually smoked pot like
maybe she has I know probably I guess
but she came out in the same interview
we don't have time to go through all of
it she said that she she smoked pot
while listening to Tupac and Snoop Dogg
in college first of all with the music
again she's Khan she's trying to relate
to people through these really basic
things these really lowest common
denominator things because you can't
talk about her record she can't talk
about her professional life so she's
talking about music she's talking I mean
music is how little children relate to
each other this is how you had make
friends in middle school she said I like
Eric Clapton oh I like Eric Clapton okay
now we're friends oh I like some really
indie thing that you totally have never
heard of oh yeah I really like that
super indie thing - yeah now that's
that's how little children talk to each
other because it's extraordinarily
shallow and inoffensive so some people
persist in this through college but
usually people grow out of it at some
point you you relate to people and you
become friends based on other things
such as circumstances or mutual friends
sometimes a shared interest or activity
or you're working together or something
a little deeper than you know yeah I
really like that cool indie
you know so that's she's relating to
people in the way that children relate
to each other because she necessarily
has to relate to people in a really
shallow way one because the deeper
essence of her career is off the table
now it's off limits and to because her
voters are shallow they're just shy I
don't know how else to put it
they're shallow they're thinking about
politics in a shallow way the green New
Deal which she supports could have been
written in crayon and this is not just
invective this is not just ad hominem
the things she's talking about our
really shallow and that's why she
launches her campaign on the mood mix
and the music she listens to this is
this is what she's doing here but the
trouble with this mood mix the trouble
with how she smoked pot in college and
listened to snoop diggity Doo dad and
the other guy Tupac is that she
graduated college in 1986 and Tupac
didn't come out with his debut album
until 91 and Snoop Dogg didn't come out
with his debut album until 93 and he
didn't get acquitted on his drive-by
shooting charge until 97 I guess that's
neither here nor there was 96 I forget
she couldn't have listened to these guys
and smoked pot while in college so it's
two questions then one has she been just
smoking pot for years like after law
school and she's just really listening
to snoop and Tupac and all that or is
she just faking it to try to seem
likable I actually think the more likely
answer is the latter I think this is the
Hillary Clinton carrying hot sauce
around line just on steroids I think
it's just the way higher up version of
that so things things are so bad for
Democrats this week that even fake Vichy
squishy I'm a Republican but I'm not
that kind of Republican fake
conservatives or giving up on them even
Steve Schmidt whose entire life now
whose total career is just talking about
how awful conservatives are and how he
wishes he were in a right-winger even
Steve Schmidt walked off his own podcast
because he has had it with the left this
week does he really mean that attacks on
incomes Oh
ten million dollars at 70% which is
widely popular with the American people
is ridiculous is that an adult
conversation yeah I think he thinks it's
ridiculous and it's confiscatory and
that it's anti-growth that would be his
point what is will Derek Jeter another
athlete not hit another home run because
they're gonna get taxed at 70 what's the
economic behavior that he thinks it's
anti-growth other than his own pocket
Adam visible Steve he got again to the
question ah you got it Steve
oh the interview ended there yeah it
ended there
oh what a what beautiful schadenfreude
oh by the way what a great way this guy
Steve Schmidt deserves everything he
gets from his new friends on the Left
Steve he's just so unnecessarily catty
and mean and backstabbing to his former
conservative friends
he made his whole life working for
Republicans and the first chance he gets
he he says no no I I want to be with the
cool kids no I want to be with the
Democrats there no those conservatives
are so bad oh so he deserves exactly
what he gets for hanging around with
these snakes cuz he's a snake himself
I'm really happy about that I hope that
he's a lesson to all conservatives to
not be that guy remember who your
friends are have a little self-respect
have a little integrity have a little
loyalty and don't try to just virtue
signal to a bunch of degenerates and try
to say no please left love me love I'm a
good one I'm the good one they're the
bad ones so I really love that but I
love that even Steve Schmidt can't take
them anymore Steve Schmidt I guess
Schmidt is advising a either Howard
Schultz or a super PAC for Howard
Schultz and Howard Schultz is this
moderate Democrat kind of a center left
center right guy and the left he's Steve
Schmidt is learning a lesson in real
time nothing is ever good enough for the
left he's gonna come and to appease them
means they're gonna eat you last and he
walked off this is BS ah very pleased
that Howard Schultz is saying this very
pleased that Steve Schmidt is saying
this very pleased that a lot of
Democrats are seeing this a great start
to the week
for conservatives a really tough start
for Democrats and it's only Tuesday
mmm join me tomorrow I'll try to keep
the levels in the cup down so we don't
all drown come back again tomorrow in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show see them
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19